I need a suit suit you take care of the
suit I'll take care of the music we
start off in the iron spider suit that
was amazing
obviously we have the homecoming suit
which is very dear to my heart I love
that suit
I forgot that I can't pitch my face and
then there's the stealth suit which is
my favorite suit because it's totally
different and totally fresh the idea
behind the suit is Peter Parker doesn't
want to be seen as spider-man in Europe
around Nick Fury bones him this costume
coming out the shield special locks
world absolute mystery it's great it's
awesome it's kind of Captain America
like with a spider-man twist do you
think that's fine no no no it's like a
European robot version of them I was
actually really among the other days
it's not nice it looks pretty bad
[Music]
so the black and red suit is like
wearing a work of art it looks so
realistic that it feels like you should
be able to climb walls and you should be
able to shoot webs and the way that it's
made is an homage to The Godfather of
the MCU the world needs the next Iron
Man it's a hard path
the life of a hero
[Music]
people depend on you
even if you were in a battle sometimes
they die I don't know if I could be the
next Iron Man
got gifts Parker the world needs that
hey friends are in trouble
the question is what are you gonna do
about it superhero stuff
I gotta get you guys out of here
building jet who are you I work with
spider-man who was inspire I went
spider-man not for spider-man new plan
[Music]